well let's go back to New York now and
the show with another Ichi first that
some might say is kind of a fishy funny
name I don't know about you but as soon
as I heard Aquaman aka Jason Momoa was
getting his own movie I was all-in and
only we can take you exclusively behind
the scenes your body is constantly
working judo jujitsu fight choreography
at four and a half months stunt training
six days a week
feel pretty superhuman Aquaman's
action-packed origin story was shot on
location in Australia and Morocco so be
prepared for stunning visuals and
adventures on the high seas added bonus
Nicole Kidman rocks a gold scaly body
suit as the fishy guys mom yippee love
it was to step into something else you
really are and you bigger rate it
because of it the story resonated with
me instantly
it's not accepted here not really
accepted here definitely can identify
with that but half Native Hawaiian hunk
didn't spend as much time in the water
as you'd think most of the city of
Atlantis is computer generated he'd
experienced all these amazing worlds we
haven't been under the ocean yet this is
our outer space and you get a fall in
love with the idea what it's like to
have these powers and be a kid that's
fun for the family it's fun for everyone
and Jason is having fun being part of
the comic book world check out this
sweet shot of him and Marvell creator
Stan Lee at a fan convention last
January and it's a very sad day for the
Marvel Universe because we have learned
Stan passed away today at the age of 95
Nance yes certainly a sad day but what a
legacy is left behind I always look
forward to those cameos he makes every
Marvel movie
[Music]